so do you recognize any of these men I
was hiding in the bathroom stall so I
didn't see his face but I heard him he
was singing along to the music at the
bar do you remember what he was singing
I think it was that song I Want It That
Way Backstreet Boys I'm familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to I Want It That Way really
okay
you are
My Fire
number two keep it going the one
desire number three believe when I say
number four I wanted that away tell me
why ain't nothing but a heartache tell
me why ain't nothing but a mistake now
number five I never wanna hear you say
[Applause]
ah chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
God I forgot about that part don't tell
me where the next clue is hidden tell me
why tell me why from that Time Jake made
the purp sing that song you guys know
about that were any of you actually
there you've told us the story many
times and tried to recreate the moment
on several occasions
no number two and five you're off key
number three you're coming in way too
early I mean what are we even doing here
guys so which one do you think killed
your family yeah I gotta stop trying to
recapture the magic of the original and
move on anyways back to the eighth
annual Heist it